um all right well uh thank you so much
for having me i'm thrilled to be down
here to talk to you today and my
understanding is that uh presentations
down here are uh more often discussions
so i would actually encourage that so
happy to answer questions uh as i go
along
uh before i dive into my slides there's
really three things uh i would love to
impart to you today the first one i have
no slides for but i've been working on
climate change for 25 years and it has
become a pretty significant moral issue
for me and there's many ways that you
can look at that
but one of the ways i look at is when i
drove down here today i was up at five
o'clock so i'd get here on time is i put
a bunch of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere i got all the benefit of
driving down here but that's going to be
impacting our climate system for
centuries to come so i get the benefit
i'm putting the impact on future
generations i also think about that in
terms of it's those who are most
vulnerable who are going to suffer the
most
um so it's those who are young those who
are old those who are sick and those who
are lowest down on the socioeconomic
rung
the second thing is i think we really
have to get beyond this conversation of
the economy versus the environment
especially here in new england we have
to think about the economy and the
environment and i would argue that our
economic well-being in the future
actually is predicated on our dealing
with this issue and i think we can lead
the nation in the world if we really
want to figure out this problem it would
be really good for jobs it would be
really good for innovation and i think
it would be really good for this region
and the the third point uh is i i'm
gonna uh sort of propose this hypothesis
it's coming out of uh some conversations
today uh but i think the only way for
new england to really solve this problem
is to have its its institutions of
higher education get far more involved
in actually figuring out how to develop
those solutions both on the adaptation
side and both on the mitigation side and
i'll talk a little bit about that when i
talk about engagement so three sort of
themes running through what i'm going to
talk about today
before i dive in i thought i might share
a couple of pictures from my latest
adventure so when i'm not actually
talking about climate change in new
england i am by training an ice core
paleoclimatologist
that's how i really got my start so i'm
a geochemist by training and this past
year we actually drilled a suite of ice
cores from denali national park off a
mountain called mount hunter so this is
mount hunter if you're really a good
rock climber you actually go up and you
climb the cauliflower ridge right here
that's not what we did we just went up
and got on helicopters and flew up
to our drill site so there's uh denali
there's forker this is the north peak of
hunter this is our afternoon late
evening ski slope that we'd come up and
do a couple of runs from but this is
this beautiful little ice cap that we
found
that flows in both directions so it
flows off here and way down in the
distance there is our little camp where
we drilled two cores uh to bedrock uh
208 meter cores down
down at the bottom that was seven years
of actually writing proposals and doing
reconnaissance to find the perfect place
to drill a core and our goal here is uh
to actually recover
we should get a thousand-year record and
we're going to reconstruct precipitation
up in central alaska for which we really
don't have any uh solid records we did a
lot of work with gpr
radar to actually figure out where
exactly to drill the core and we get
these these beautiful sets of images and
this is going sort of from the south to
the north so actually if i go back here
that's
that that radar profile goes along the
ridge here so the ice flows that way so
the ice is flowing into and out of this
figure
flowing this way and so you can see we
drilled our cord one of the deepest
parts but right exactly on the divide
where the ice is moving apart you can
see some weird reflections in here which
we actually think are buried crevasses
which is a whole other interesting
problem in a separate little research
project
this is our little
camp up there this is our drill tent
completely powered our entire drilling
operation with renewable energy uh solar
panels and
wind turbines we had a big five kilowatt
honda generator up there uh that worked
really well but we didn't need it
because the sun and the wind actually
did better than we expected up there and
here's the portable drill it all has to
break down and fit into a helicopter
this was one that we developed actually
about 15 years ago with a separate
nsf-funded grant
uh i would say there's rarely a singular
picture you can use to and capture an
entire field program but this is it this
is the bottom of our 208 meter core and
you can see we're going from the clear
ice which dominates the 207 meters above
this and you can see we're getting at
right down to the glacier uh but we flew
those out to base camp and then back to
talkeetna and we trucked them to denver
and we cut them up and just last friday
they arrived at unh so they're safe and
sound in my freezer collaborative
program with uh dartmouth and um
uh university of maine uh and we'll
start analyzing those and should have
some results in a couple years
specifically to look at precipitation uh
yeah so we've done uh a suite in um
uh the south western yukon territory
around mount logan so we actually
drilled we i didn't personally but our
team we got a core from the summit at 18
000 feet we got japanese got a core at
14 000 feet and we got another core at
eclipse at 10 000 feet and one of the
main goals was to look at precipitation
variability in those cores
and then we also did it on the penny ice
cap in the eastern arctic but it wasn't
really as successful and there's been a
really big nasa program really trying to
understand the dynamics of the greenland
ice sheet so they've done quite a bit of
sort of cores all around greenland to
figure out how the accumulation rate has
varied with time because they want that
to calibrate their various satellites
that measure the altitude and the
reflectivity etc of the surface so yeah
reconstructing snow accumulation is a
pretty
i would say standard measurement on ice
cores you just have to go where there's
enough snow
so here's uh here's one of the here's
this is our rationale on why we drilled
on denali this is actually a correlation
coefficient map from
annual precipitation in talkeetna which
is not far from mount hunter it's where
we do all our logistics from and then
we're we're comparing it to other
instrumental records from around alaska
then in stars i'm showing you the ice
core records that we have so up here you
can see talking alaska june to october
precipitation with a shallow core that
we got several years ago and we've got a
reasonably good correlation even though
they're separated by about 12 000 feet
and 45 miles we think we can get a
representative measure of snow
accumulation but you can also see
there's this really big bullseye pattern
and we can do probably get a reasonable
record from central alaska but it's not
going to tell us a lot of what's going
on down here say at mount washington
waddington where eric steig and his
colleagues at uw actually have a core
it's a completely opposite sign so
really important to develop these
regional records of climate change so we
better understand what happened in
central alaska and the thousand years
will take us through the little ice age
and the medieval warm period
all right
that was just what i did for fun uh this
summer and here's uh what i'm really
going to talk about today is this notion
of going local really trying to better
understand regional climate change to
help decision makers and i want to start
this off
with this definition that we've
developed at the university of new
hampshire of engaged scholarship i've
actually talked about this with several
people today but this is really
i would say a place where higher
education has a tremendous opportunity
to help society solve some significant
problems it's not about going out and
being a consultant and just figuring out
just helping them but it's also of
getting scholarship about it so you can
see in the definition sort of mutually
beneficial is a really important part of
the definition a collaboration with
community partners to apply relevant
knowledge to directly benefit
the public and i would
argue that much of the research i've
been doing over the course of the past
10 years on new england actually falls
in this realm of engaged scholarship
uh so this is a question that i ask a
lot of my audiences is were you ready
for the storm and i was just talking
with guy the guy the video guy
about how about this time last year uh
we were actually suffering you guys had
something on the order of a foot to a
foot and a half of snow down here for
snowmageddon snowtober don't know what
the meteorologist down here uh called it
but lots of power images people started
to go out
and
and
buy generators so the question is were
we ready for that storm and i would
argue that we weren't because we'd never
really experienced the foot of snow at
the end of october when there were still
leaves on the trees so those trees would
fall over and uh and hit the power lines
we've had several large floods in
southern new hampshire and coastal
massachusetts that's one
we weren't really ready for that big
precipitation event at all and it
wreaked havoc
in southern new hampshire
certainly not ready for irene that came
through and hit vermont and all of that
uh water and while they've tried to
rebuild i think what i've been hearing
for most of them is fema wouldn't let
them rebuild the way they wanted to they
had to rebuild the way it was which is
similar to what we've heard chris
christie talk about new jersey we
weren't ready for the storm but when we
come in with our billions of dollars we
were rebuilding the way that it used to
be although there are some examples
there
all right so that's my framing i'm going
to talk a little bit about climate
change
it's great you've had some climate
modelers here before me because i'm not
a climate modeler i just use the output
from climate models uh so great you've
had um
uh
what's his name from columbia horton
is he talked to yeah and then you had
linda mearns here so i'm going to talk
more about the results that about uh the
models i'll talk a little bit about them
uh but like any good paleoclimatologist
at one point i asked the question so how
has climate changed across the northeast
over the last hundred years and i
couldn't really find an example anywhere
so we collected all of the available
meteorological data did a pretty
significant quality assurance quality
control on this actually adam wilson
who's now here was a graduate student
who helped us out with these our first
effort at this
so here's winter time uh temperature
trends across the northeast going back
to 1895 up to the present the blue is
the year-to-year variability uh in uh in
temperature and it's pretty clear that
if you don't like one winter in new
england just wait because the following
winter is certainly almost certainly
going to be different but you can see
this long-term trend of temperature
increase by the way i don't use
scientific units anymore because i'm
almost always talking to the public and
they don't understand centigrade in
centimeters so i've put everything into
fahrenheit so i hope you bear with me
but you can really see that the rate of
warming has increased substantially over
the course of the last four to five
decades in fact it's doubled so that
we've seen temperature increases across
much of the region on the order to three
to four uh degrees fahrenheit so the
size of the dot represents that linear
interpolation of the data from 1965 to
2008. in our paper we did a pretty
significant sensitivity analysis to see
you know does it really matter what year
you start the trend in is it 1960 all
the way up to 1975 and it doesn't really
change much it's a pretty robust finding
and you can also see that it's it's
robust across the entire region right
the whole region has been warming
significantly and three to four degrees
fahrenheit is a big deal
if you've been living here i'm sure you
have seen the change in wintertime
climate over that time period
another thing we've looked at is extreme
precipitation events and we've defined
these a whole bunch of different ways
i'm showing you the results of of one of
these analysis and its trends in four
inches of precipitation in 48 hours and
we do 48 hours because we arbitrarily
cut meteorological records at midnight
or at seven o'clock in the morning so
you often get a storm that lasts a short
period of time but may actually go over
that split so we look at it in 48 hours
and so what you're seeing is the change
over five decades of events
per decade and so you're seeing in many
cases especially sort of where we're at
in coastal new hampshire coastal maine
and massachusetts not so much down here
uh but on the on the cape and another
region we're seeing a significant
increase of sort of 2.5 to 5 to 7.5
events so traditionally we get two to
four of these per decade so we're seeing
an increase on the order of two to four
to six per decade more than a doubly of
extreme precipitation events and when
that rain falls on watersheds that we're
developing and creating more impervious
surface it ends up in more floods across
the region which is exactly what we've
experienced here's another way to look
at that just a a record from durham new
hampshire four inch precipitation events
by decade the average as you go back in
time was sort of on the on the order of
one to two to three events per decade
and you can see we're seeing this steady
climb so we're now up to essentially one
event per year with no signs of that
slowing down in the future
another way to look at the way our
precipitation has changed is to look at
the information that engineers use for
design storms and in this case the 24
hour 100 year rainfall design storm if
you go and talk to most engineers
they'll be very familiar with this
national weather service technical paper
40 tp40 rainfall frequency analysis and
it was sort of these maps that you had
to interpolate from and for coastal new
hampshire that design storm
was
you had to design sort of anything that
you were building uh for uh to deal with
6.3 inches of water uh in a 24-hour
period that was a 100-year design storm
and that was developed on data collected
meteorological data collected from
1938-1957
that is still in use today and the
engineers i talked to say well maybe i'd
use something else but by law i'm
actually obligated because it's been
sort of embedded in the way that
engineers work it's really difficult to
change that culture but recently um the
northeast regional climate center at
cornell has developed what's being
called the the cornell atlas which
actually updates this analysis up to
include data up through 2008 so the
design storm
in
southeastern new hampshire now is 8.5
inches and a few enlightened engineering
firms use that number but most still use
6.3 and the question i ask is what other
decisions significant decisions do we
make based on data that was collected
before
the 1960s i would say not many that's
even for the
young among you that's even before the
internet was developed
so yet another way to look at how our
climate has changed is to look at how
much money the states in the new england
states have actually requested from the
federal government
for presidentially declared disasters
and emergency declarations
so everything is in 2012 millions of
dollars here and you'll see that it has
increased significantly i actually have
to update this but as i was getting the
data like the government shutdown
and i couldn't go back in time so for
new hampshire i have it back to 1990 and
outside of 1998 with the big ice storm
that we had it tends to be uh pretty low
um
but you can see sort of big storms you
know five as
uh especially affecting massachusetts so
that was big uh flooding mother's day
storms patriot day storms here and then
you can see a huge hit that vermont took
associated with irene and then a little
bit of sandy this one was a big march
precipitation event that affected lots
of rhode island but you can see we're
beginning to ask for lots more money so
these weather events that are affecting
the region are actually having a
significant impact on our society
and once again that's not just because
climate's changed but it's also because
we built in a whole bunch of vulnerable
areas and we're probably causing
more problems with flooding because of
what we actually pave
we've also looked at climate change
across the region by collecting ice out
dates so we haven't done this people
collect ice out date records and they've
actually been collected by
the usgs folks who work up in maine so
here's two of my favorite there's lake
winnipesaukee on the top so we've got
ice out dates going back to the late
1880s and that's defined as the day that
the mount washington which is a tour
boat can get into every port
on the little tour that it does so it's
a pretty been a pretty solid definition
over time then there's another one
on lake sunapee and you can see that
since 1970 the ice is coming out from
those lakes earlier and earlier this is
a particular significance to me because
i love to play pond hockey it's my pond
hockey team over here i wouldn't think
many people had pond hockey teams but
there's this great event called the
pond hockey classic that occurs on lake
winnipesaukee and back here not this
past winter but the winter before we
actually couldn't play because the ice
had not come in by february 1st in
central new hampshire that really
wretched winter that we had not too long
ago
all right and i'm sure you're all aware
especially living not so far from the
coast that our seas are continuing to
rise this is three tidal gauge records
from portland
boston and new york you could see a
pretty significant sea level rise a
little bit faster
recently in boston and new york compared
to portland because boston and new york
are experiencing coastal subsidence and
portland is not so much
all right so that's how climate's
changed uh the big question i would
argue is how is climate going to change
in the future
uh so this is i would say some
relatively old results now but i was
involved with a group of 50 people that
participate in the development of this
northeast climate impact assessment and
i worked with catherine hayjo on the
climate part of this and then we
actually had teams that looked at the
impacts of climate change on a whole
variety of sectors
so we published uh what's what's
becoming i think a pretty well-cited
paper in climate dynamics in 2007 about
climate and hydrological change across
the northeast and then i added a special
edition of 14 papers and adaptation and
mitigation of climate change so if you
want to get lots of details you can go
here
or you can go to the website so i'm just
going to sort of gloss over a couple of
of the results from this report
but in the intervening years we've sort
of developed what i would say we've sort
of taken the climate assessment an
additional step so if you think about
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change as the global climate assessment
then we've got the national climate
assessment which is
still in draft are you part of that one
it's supposed to come out soon
it was the draft report came out in the
spring
i was involved in a little bit but
haven't heard but it should come out
this year
and then there's a regional climate
assessments we've actually gone and
taken it down to the watershed scale
because we've been getting requests
from key stakeholders resource managers
and planners
asking you know how is climate going to
change in my backyard like i can't i
can't use a northeast average i need to
know how temperature is changed in
portland maine
and so we've done one for the great bay
watershed we've done one for the casco
bay watershed i'm doing one right now
for a sustainable communities initiative
funded by hud for the state of new
hampshire and then we've also done this
flooding
project in the lamprey river which i'll
talk about so i've sort of mixed a lot
of these results together to show you
different examples of how climate
assessments can be used to help drive
decision making we've taken the pretty
standard approach that's been developed
by the ipcc of looking at different
emission scenarios
the ipcc comes up with a whole bunch
more emission scenarios and this and
more recently they've come up with
representative concentration pathways
but we really simplify this for our
stakeholders so we've really looked at
how climate might change in a high
emission scenario the a1fi where global
population grows to 9 billion by the
middle of the century we behave a little
differently now and we help the
developing world come out of poverty but
they do that by using a lot of fossil
fuel energy and in the b1 which is a low
emission scenario same population uh
same socio-economic scenario we just
invest in renewables and energy
efficiency so we use then use these to
drive a whole set of uh global climate
models and then we look at that output
and uh i work with again my colleague at
texas tech catherine hey ho who has
statistically downscaled that so we've
we've done it we've looked at results
from a little bit of dynamical
downscaling but really
we're focusing on uh statistical
downscaling and we've really used output
from three or four models in part
because they cover a range of
sensitivities in part because they do
well in the northeast so they get the
dynamics of sort of the jet stream and
the and how our
how the polar front moves north and
south they capture the north atlantic
oscillation
in a reasonable fashion and so we've
done the downscaling both to
meteorological stations but also to a
grid to answer
a series of different questions for
stakeholders so here's a pretty standard
output from one of these assessments is
you show people how regional temperature
is going to change
right so this is my work here here's the
historically how temperature has changed
across the entire northeast and then the
colored lines represent the model output
when i first started this um you i i
suspect you're realizing this by now i'm
a data guy i'm a paleoclimatologist i
collect ice cores uh so i sort of said
you know do your does your global model
output even capture the change that we
see across the northeast and i was
moderately surprised that the warming
we've seen was actually captured by the
ensemble mean at least of the three
models we used for this project what the
global climate models aren't capturing
even when you're downscaling it is
actually the significant temperature
increase in winter and i think that's
happening because they're not getting
the snow dynamics right
this is an ensemble mean of output from
three models that's then been the winter
when you do it on a seasonal basis the
winter's not showing four degrees
no it's showing what it's about half
that about two degrees two degrees so
the mean change
is about two degrees here so that's yeah
it's sort of capturing winter warming
but only up two degrees so about what
the average is yeah as opposed to that
enhanced warming in winter
is the summer warming in the models yep
yeah so we're not capturing that's that
seasonal differentiate
differentiation um
a couple things i think you guys
probably know this already but i say it
whenever i show this figure by the
middle of the century right 2040 2050
there's really no difference between the
models that's an amount of warming that
we're committed to and so whether or not
you want to say the word adaptation you
better start realizing that this is a
world that really we cannot avoid and
we're just going to have to deal with
and so better that we start thinking
about that now so we can spend our
limited resources in a wise way over a
longer period of time and then
conversely the decisions we make today
about how we produce and how we use
energy
globally are going to determine what the
temperature is by the end of the century
so under low emission scenarios we see
temperature going up you know in the
order of four to five to six degrees
fahrenheit at about twice that under the
high emission scenario and i would argue
this is a change we can probably adapt
to and this would be really difficult to
adapt to so let's put that into a little
bit more perspective as part of the
northeast climate impact assessment we
developed these sort of migrating state
images
i hope you've seen them they tend to be
pretty popular
what are summers going to feel like in
connecticut in the future so under the
higher emission scenario
we would expect that connecticut uh
by the end of the century would feel
like it does in south carolina or maybe
georgia today
so summers would be really hot and
probably pretty long conversely under
the low emissions scenario right they're
still going to feel like they currently
do in
west virginia i'm not sure if the
politics change with the climate
so it's going to be either
some warmer or a lot warmer you can also
look at that in terms of the number of
hot days and so we did that for a number
of different cities here are the results
for hartford connecticut traditionally
this area would experience about 15 days
that felt like they were hotter than 90
degrees fahrenheit
most of those days are probably going to
have bad air quality too because those
warm temperatures are often associated
with
polluted air coming into the region
under the high emission scenario by the
end of the century we'd expect something
this most of the summer right 75 to 80
days per year that felt that they were
hotter than 90 degrees so 90 days in the
summer it would essentially be
a heat wave
any way you look at extreme
precipitation events we see them getting
bigger and more frequent in the future
so overall precipitation goes up but uh
high magnitude low frequency events
increase as well and there's sort of
lots of ways that you can look at that
and i think it's an area where we need
lots more research to really understand
exactly what's going to happen
we also used the vic model out of
princeton which is a water balance model
to look at how drought might also change
in the future
so we're not just looking at inputs of
precipitation but minus evaporation so
these are results looking at so sorry
this is the historical record of drought
number of droughts in a 30-year period
you can see if we looked at short-term
drought one to three months
we experience a drought sort of once
every so ten droughts in a 30-year
period on average
under the high emission scenario we
would expect to see
somewhere on the order of 30
droughts in a 30-year period which means
we've got a drought every year and that
drought is certainly going to come in
summertime as we precipitation none of
the models really show an increase in
precipitation in summer whether you
statistically or dynamically downscale
them but we see dramatically increasing
summertime temperatures so we see more
drought in summer and i would argue
that's something that new england really
isn't prepared to deal with that you can
see the changes are much lower under the
low emissions scenario
uh so we took that climate information
as i said we gave it to a number of
different sectors so marine resources
and coastal infrastructure and and
forests and agriculture
so you can all read it go read about
that if you want to show one of my
favorites which is uh the health of ski
areas in the future so we actually had
specific models that were run for each
ski area sort of their slope
how much snow they got and we provided
the climate indicators and we said that
if a ski area was going to be viable in
the future it had to meet two criteria
it had to be open up for 100 days a year
which is a pretty good rule of thumb and
70 percent of the time it had to be open
at christmas so if it meant both of
those it would be viable
one of those that would be vulnerable if
it meant neither of those it would be
highly vulnerable so end of the century
under the high emission scenario there's
only one area that remains viable for
skiing across the northeast and that
sugar sugarloaf and sunday river and i
love skiing so you can guess where i've
bought my little winter cabin
all other places either become
vulnerable or highly vulnerable which
suggests that there's really not going
to be much of a ski industry here by the
end of the end of the century under the
high emissions scenario and it's even
worse for snowmobiling
there's a vulnerability piece there too
we could get into but those winter
recreation areas really support a lot of
rural new hampshire they tend to be not
near big cities so if you take that away
you begin to question what people in
rural rural actually rural parts of new
england are going to work on are going
to do
all right so this is the more this is
the more recent climate assessment that
we're doing for the state of new
hampshire because that northeast climate
impact assessment wasn't good enough for
them it's like i want to know how
temperature is going to change in my
town it's a really common question so
we've actually done a whole new set of
statistically
statistical downscaling and we've used
these temperature records going back to
1960 for about 35 stations across new
hampshire so we're getting really good
coverage right lots of detail here so i
can tell somebody sort of you know in
coastal new hampshire what's going to
happen what has happened and what will
happen with their temperature depending
on the emission scenario versus sort of
a difference up in koas county and this
regional uh information is just really
valued by a whole range of different
stakeholders i'm constantly asked for
this so how's temperature going to
change i've averaged this so here we've
got southern new hampshire right it's
almost an identical curve to what i
showed you but i can now say it's for
southern new hampshire and stakeholders
actually are more willing to use this
information than a new england wide
average and again i put it into
fahrenheit so that they can understand
it you can see a big difference again
between the high emissions and the low
emissions scenario i can show the same
picture for northern new hampshire it
says pretty much the same story but it's
actually for northern new hampshire
stations
in these models do you use all the
instrument data up to the present and
then stop using it or do you stop
a few decades short of the presence how
will your model
your model to data why that so so i
don't run the model so that's important
but no the way that we do it is we take
1960 to 2012 and we split that in half
so we train it on half of it and then we
see how well it does and then even
before we do that we do a significant
quality assurance quality control on the
meteorological data because shockingly
there's a whole bunch of bad
meteorological data out there
actually it's almost it's almost endless
between the station moves and cities
growing up around them and instrument
changes and observers who just didn't
want to read their instruments like
every saturday
which sort of introduces a bias into the
into the data set
so no we use half for training and half
for testing and then we use that
relationship uh to actually downscale
statistically downscale
so we do it we do the downscaling for
individual stations because i love to
tell people we use the data from your
meteorological station and here's what
the results show and they get that much
more than a grid cell
right it's it
they they intuitively understand that
we've used data from a place instead of
just chopping up the earth into a bunch
of grid cells
even though obviously you have to do
that to run the models but it's easier
to explain to them
so a very similar set of results to what
i just showed you for hartford
connecticut you know number of days
hotter than nine degrees fahrenheit this
is usually the
i get from the audience when i show them
this graph because nobody wants to live
in south carolina if they're living in
summers in new hampshire so southern new
hampshire you know less than 10 sort of
uh seven to eight
days above 90 degrees fahrenheit and
then by the end of the century you can
see we're up around 55
days per summer hotter than 90 degrees
fahrenheit northern new hampshire as you
would expect it's actually a little bit
less so the people in northern new
hampshire like this because they're not
going to be as hot and they're they're
really not as used to heat as well
because it tends to be cooler up there
i'll point out that you know and as you
know paleo models don't get latino
gradients right they they usually
underestimate temperature changes in
higher latitudes under a particular
global forcing so that that
probably should be viewed as a minimum
in in
models
we can't reconstruct greenhouse climate
distribution very well
and i would add we're still probably not
getting the snow dynamics right on here
the winter is wrong so you know at a
minimum the winter is wrong but the
zonal gradients
often
can't be reconstructed well but i'm not
sure where that begins i mean where does
that begin is it would it begin that uh
you know do the gradients
fail at very high latitudes or is it
more of a upper
upper mid latitudes do you know
so we're not we're not quite mid to high
right we're oh mid 45 yeah yeah yeah i
think you're i think we're
i mean we may be in a zone where it's
better better you know modeled
but uh certainly the latitudinal
temperature gradients fail that's them
in paleo
reconstructions these models don't work
well
horizontal gradients as you move further
for sound
i don't really have a feel for how much
the
the regional variability change changes
um
how much larger are they than changes
among your ensemble members for example
um when you're looking on these kinds of
scales
uh so i i think that's a really good
question you might sort of couch that in
sort of how much uncertainty do you have
around the results and can i actually
take a number that that we've developed
for all of the northeast is that is that
reasonable for somebody sitting in new
hampshire and if if
i would argue that it's probably not
that much better i can give you a number
for your specific location but it's
probably not that much better but they
want the number for their specific
location so we hear that again and again
and again and even though it's not
sort of really any different from what
i've provided for the regional
temperature it's uh i i i i don't think
it's a lot better now when you get to
precipitation i would say it's probably
even a little bit more challenging
i mean we are downscaling to specific
meteorological records so we are
capturing that sort of on-the-ground
spatial variability of places that are
are wetter or not so wet but i think we
have research especially on sort of this
frequency of big precipitation events in
the future and how they're going to vary
regionally because the statistical
downscaling we're doing is really making
this big assumption that the connection
between global climate and regional and
local climate is going to stay the same
and you know we've done our others have
done regional climate modeling dynamical
downscaling to show that that's probably
reasonable in coastal new hampshire uh
sorry in
new england maybe not there's a bias
that happens along the coast that
modelers haven't quite figured out
so i don't actually know how much better
the information is it's a great point
but i know the people making the
decisions
need the local information in order to
move forward
did it answer your question is that
shocking
all right so that's uh day's hotter than
nine degrees fahrenheit we have it turns
out we actually have many more
meteorological stations that have good
precipitation records and then we have
good temperature records which was
actually
sort of news to me but now there's this
wonderful new network that's run by noaa
called cocorahs community collaborative
community rain hail and snow network so
we're getting a lot more actually useful
information but that didn't go back to
1960. we now have 300 people across the
state of new hampshire measuring
precipitation and about two-thirds of
those recorded daily so we're getting
much better
records of
variability and precipitation so same
thing we downscaled to all of these
locations and so i'm going to go ahead
and do how our forage precipitation
event is going to change
in the future for both southern new
hampshire and northern new hampshire you
can see that we have we see this
increase over time so here's a good
modeling question because i always get
asked this question when i show this
this model output to people is that in
the short term the low emission scenario
results in more extreme precipitation
events than the high emission scenario
and i really have no idea why that's
happening i also say there's probably
not a huge difference between what i'm
showing you in terms of these models and
i could put uncertainty bars on it but
that our er or standard deviations or
mean errors but that really starts to
confuse a set of stakeholders that i
work with you can see that it appears
that southern new hampshire right is
going to have more events than northern
new hampshire but that's driven in a big
part because of in the past southern new
hampshire has had sort of you know 4.3
events per decade over the period 1980
to 2009 whereas northern new hampshire
has had a little bit more than two so
that increase in the future is actually
capturing uh what's happened in the past
and probably reflecting that that
southern new hampshire is tend to be
much closer to the coast than northern
new hampshire does
i don't need to go on about this but
but what would the error bars look like
on that what's the standard deviation so
we'd have um if i could i don't have a
picture of it here but if you looked at
the actual towns uh across northern new
hampshire so if we're looking at the at
the standard deviation around the mean
um from from so we get the ensemble mean
output and i look at all the different
towns there would be towns up here that
might have uh one to two events on
average per year and some that had uh
15.
and then if you looked at the output
from the change from the ensemble mean
uh the minimum the maximum uh would be
uh i probably 30
around those so if you look at the
minimum value that comes out of any
model for any given year and the maximum
value and you look at how that varies
about the mean it would be pretty
significant
and if somebody said you know should i
be designing a system for 2070 where i
have to deal with 12 forage
precipitation events in the future i'd
say no you need to be designing things
where you're going to have more big
extreme precipitation events in the
future and in fact i would say just
design it to the climate that you have
now would be a much better
step than designing to a climate that
existed in the middle of the century and
we're still well behind on that sort of
i don't know if you guys are having that
culvert discussion in your towns but
it's really dominating how big a culvert
should be put in when we replace
culverts it's a big um
sort of department of public works
question so you have a higher higher
precipitation events but you have drier
you have more drought so
this is just a calculation of eop for
summer months is that the
so this is so so the drought comes out
of the vic model now we're just looking
at precipitation
right so you're getting higher
precipitation but you're i mean so your
models are
your calculation of drought is that the
temperature about evaporation is
exceeding precipitation these are events
rather than
um
then then average uh you know
rainfall there's a number of events but
that doesn't stick to the
i'm sorry yeah it does because it's
greater than four inches
in 48 hours but that
i'm just trying to i was wondering how
to think about it because
uh you know okay it's a storm event it's
flooding is what you're talking about
because it can't be absorbed into the
soil
and so and then the drought is
calculating
uh e o and p
for soil moisture and that's an average
and uh but on a seasonal basis right or
is that in that was that
monthly but do most of these extreme
precipitation events happen in winter
uh in the shoulder seasons and winter so
the answer to your question is that
if you look at all this output no none
of the models really show any increase
in precipitation in summer it tends to
stay pretty flat so we see an increase
in precipitation in winter in the
shoulder seasons so the drought is
really being driven by
no increase in summer precipitation
increase evaporation
but overall we get more precipitation it
goes up anywhere from sort of 10 to 30
percent but in the other seasons and
actually primarily in winter
and those are when the big precipitation
events and think about what's happened
in terms of flooding right it doesn't
really flood that much in summer we're
not getting the big precipitation events
as much but also there tends to be right
the ecosystem can suck that water up
much more effectively in the summer
so the average precipitation in the
winter is that is it i know that you
were calculating a
temperature you were looking at you know
your relationships for the snow for your
ski resorts you know or going look so
precipitation was going down in the
winter or i should say melting versus
precipitation was increasing through the
winter scenarios and that was a minimum
because you're i'm just trying to get
all the my you know balances right
you're you're
you can't capture the recent warming in
winter so any estimate of winter winter
effects is a minimum it's conservative
yes and so
so you could very well be experiencing
droughts in the
winter as well even though precipitation
of events are occurring in the winter
you just don't there's uncertainty there
most of these precipitation events are
occurring in when once again this is
what
the big events yeah yes spring the
shoulder seasons in winter
and winter and you can't capture the
warming in the winter winter so
you know when they're getting big events
it doesn't speak to droughts in the
winter correct
and so yeah so um
a really important point is that
you know models are useful tools and
they're providing us this potential
window into the future
but there's some pretty significant
limitations and another one is you know
gcms are not very good at capturing
extreme events until the paleoclimate
community says by the way you have to
capture this really big extreme event
that we've seen in the past so there's i
think there's you know some potential
significant thresholds that we might
cross that the outputs from the the
downscale gcms are not showing us as
well so
i think overall the conclusion is that
we're looking at a set of probably
minimum changes is right on
snow covered days speaking of snow uh so
even though we're not capturing that
that warming winter we do look at snow
covered days and this is this is
actually a pretty good measure from
meteorological stations because people
look out their window at a patch that
they look at every day and say does it
have snow on it or not
so it's it's it's it's not an easy
measure to mess up
um and so you know in most of uh
southern new hampshire sort of a hundred
days of snow on the ground is a pretty
good winter and we see that uh
decreasing substantially under the high
emission scenarios to about half that
whereas we retain you know 80 percent of
it
under the low emission scenarios and
then northern new hampshire we don't see
as much of a decrease but a decrease
nonetheless
all right so that's uh so i've showed
you the results from the northeast
climate impact assessment the northeast
i've showed you some results from a new
hampshire assessment which uh we're
rolling out uh this fall sometime i'm
gonna transition to talking about well
how do you go from the extreme
precipitation to more flooding
uh so this was a project uh on assessing
specifically flooding in the lamprey
river and as i said that's a picture
from uh the patriots day storm in
newmarket uh so lamprey river watershed
it's about 214 square miles it's
reasonably big for a new england
watershed but it's not you know the
merrimack or the connecticut drains in
the great bay so this is the area in
southern new hampshire that it's looking
at and what we're really focused on is
what is going to be the change in uh in
the size and magnitude frequency sorry
what's going to be the change in the
magnitude of a 100 year
flooding event
and so to do that you have to do two
things you can't only look at climate
change you have to look at land use
change and if there's anything i've
learned over the last five years is that
climate change is probably easier to
deal with than land use change
so
what humans are going to do with the
landscape in the future
it turns out to be it's a really
challenging uh
scenario set of scenarios to develop so
what we did in this case this took us a
year to sort of come up with a very
simple representation but we actually
looked at how we first started with
population we wanted to drive everything
with population but it turns out that
the ratio between the acres developed in
population growth is changing over time
at least in southern new hampshire so
people per capita are taking up a larger
piece of developed land as our
population growth uh which is not
encouraging so here's uh the development
for residential development and here's
development for commercial development
and we actually just put exponential
curves through those so that by the end
of the century the land that's developed
actually occupies about half of the area
of the watershed and we see this
significant increase in commercial and
industrial development
so we had to do that first we had to
build out the watershed uh sort of you
know how many how many developments are
there going to be and then we actually
had to lay that onto the watershed
itself so we started with a total
watershed and then we eliminated places
uh where people couldn't put houses and
then we just sort of added them to the
landscape so we did a subtraction piece
right we took out what the existing
developed land was although i'll talk
about that in a minute a minute we took
out anything that was wet
then we took out anything that was steep
and then we took out anything that was
conserved and we said it's going to be
conserved in the future and then once
we've done that we actually just
laid people onto the landscape we
started out with flat terrain we moved
to somewhat steeper terrain
and we built out closest to roads first
so we actually had a student that went
around and found out what all of the
existing zoning was in terms of
residential and commercial development
we use that so you know more denser in
in urban areas less dense so here's land
use in 2005 and we built it out to 2050.
you can see lots of development along
the roads and then we took it out to
2100 and all the development occurred on
the roads because we didn't let people
build any roads we just allowed them to
develop along those those existing roads
but you can see significant change
across the watershed
we also did allow areas to redevelop
with low impact design but i'm not going
to talk a ton about those results
we then
actually looked at climate scenarios to
figure out how precipitation would
change and we we again took uh somewhat
of an extreme here um
uh i'll explain this table in a second
but we ran uh uh four gcms we downscaled
them and we looked at the single largest
precipitation 24-hour precipitation
event that the gcm that the downscale
gcm's provided us with as the biggest
hundred year storm in the future so it
was actually from lawrence mass which is
pretty close to the watershed and it was
11.4 inches so we've got sort of
the
the the flood insurance studies or the
flood flood insurance rate maps are
based on the 6.3 inches that i showed
you from the tp40 we have current
climate that's sort of 8.5 inches we
said that went out to eight uh 2050 and
then 2100 the biggest storm was so we've
sort of bracketed this problem between
what happens today and what might happen
there at 2100
we have it both for land use now and for
climate change and then the whole
approach we took is one that's used by
the army corps of engineers in their
analysis for fema of flood plains is
it's really based on this uh curve
number so it's a relationship between
how much rain falls and how much runs
off and these curve numbers represent
different surfaces so a curve number of
about 70 is like a well-drained soil
forest curve number of 100 would be
pavement that no water would get through
and so i'm just going to show you a
couple of examples here
you can see here so if we have this a
6.3 inch event falling on a forested
service surface we'd expect three inches
of that water to run off
if you go up to 8.5 inches and you have
that curve number of 70 right you have
five inches running off that's a big
deal for an engineer right that's a big
difference in terms of the amount of
runoff you've seen if it actually if
you've developed that land to some
extent if you have a curve number of 90.
so say that's a residential development
with some lawn you can see you have
quite a bit more development and then
one of the things we did do is we also
this is a development using low impact
design where you actually store a bunch
of water actually on the property um
another way to look at the problem
so then we take these curve numbers we
looked at the watershed we looked at how
the curve number would change across all
of these small watersheds and we use
these two tools that are now embedded in
gis systems available from the us army
corps of engineer we do a hydrological
modeling with
hms and then how the water actually
flows a hydraulic modeling with heck
razz
and so then we looked at we actually
mapped the results we had lidar flown in
these areas recently so we had really
good topography and so we developed a
whole series of floodplain maps in the
future for every community in the
lamprey river watershed and we had some
big workshops and we shared all this
information so what you see it's
actually it's tough to see but the
existing hundred year flood plains are
actually in this blue hatching
and then uh the pink represents um
uh the what we would say is the updated
2005 conditions so they represent
current conditions with an 8.5 inch
event and then the orange over here
represents what the flood plains would
be
at 2100 so there's there's actually
there's been almost more change between
the flood insurance studies uh done in
the in the late 1960s early 70s and
today than there will be in the future
so in some ways we can go and tell
people hey you've already seen a lot of
change start designing for the change
that you've already seen
the maps were really instructive for a
lot of people i know they're hard to see
and we can't roll them out and look at
them so just to summarize the
significant changes that we saw this was
the flood insurance study so that's
based on the the tp40 and and how the
initial 100-year floodplains were
developed for the entire country by fema
so the change from there to what we call
current conditions in 2005 which is the
last period we have land use for
the discharge at the one usgs
gauge that we have in packers falls
actually went up 56 percent the surface
elevation of that hundred foot flood
went from uh went up 2.7 feet so that
essentially puts it from underneath the
road to over the road the bridge that
goes over packard falls and the hundred
year floodplain area actually increased
by 20 percent this is no small potatoes
when you think about most people want to
actually live by rivers so there's
there's plenty of development there
already and at some point i would argue
we have to have a pretty significant
question about how we don't develop that
area in the future then if you go from
20 2005 to 2100 you have this is an
additional increase of 66 in the
discharge additional increase of 4.4
feet in that flood so we're talking
overall right a seven foot increase and
we have flooding of an additional 14
of area i'll just show you what that
actually means on a cross section
uh well that's a good question actually
nobody's nobody asked us that in our uh
what what's the implication of
groundwater
um
so i don't actually know just from uh i
i think we would
we would i don't know
i know i guess what i'm kind of stuck on
is that we're now having this very
serious conversation about taking the
excess water that we have in the spring
and pumping it back into our aquifers so
it's going to be available for us in
summer
so the groundwater question is not so
much like how does how does it affect
flooding but how do we take this sort of
this plenty that we have and store it
because we're not going to build a big
dam in new england so let's put pump it
back into
the aquifer and that's a there's already
been two groundwater studies in the town
of durham and i think the department of
environmental services is getting ready
to permit them to put that water back in
the aquifer
but we know so little about groundwater
i think is that i have no idea what this
would do to it but i don't think
we actually know like where it's coming
from and where it's going a lot of
uncertainties there we know that you
know the coastal waters will experience
enhanced salt water incursion
so yeah but a way
like just a result of the development
and the changes in runoff
yeah i don't think we know
i certainly don't know
uh so i'll show you one example this is
a route 108 that connects new market in
durham and we point out the durham
boathouse because actually they had a
mark on the wall in the last two floods
somebody had drawn a line on the wall so
we're actually able to use that to
calibrate our models it was a really
useful piece of information i'm going to
show you a cross section on this road
and this road floods all the time right
and it's it's the major artery between
durham and new market so here's the
flood insurance study flood at
32.3 feet so that's what the 100 year
floodplain would be mapped at currently
that would be the legal hundred year
floodplain we'd argue that actually 35.2
feet is the actual
current 100-year flood plane
and those are being remapped by fema so
we should be getting a new set of flood
maps out soon which is going to show
that more people have to buy insurance
flood insurance and then when we looked
at projected 2100 year flood
you would you can see that we're now
talking right 38.9 39 feet which we're
talking about this road being under 9 to
10 feet of water
uh it's probably time to start thinking
about this if this is a major at
transportation route and then that
slight drop down to like uh 38.5 is what
the flood would be if we actually
developed in the future using uh low
impact design
so pretty big questions and they're
about to rebuild this and what's
interesting is because of the studies
we've done the town residents are asking
dot why don't you build the highway much
higher
and d ut saying we don't have to right
we've got the hundred year floodplain
study that shows we just need to do it a
little bit higher and and the town
residents are really beginning to push
the department of transportation which
luckily for us in new hampshire they're
actually beginning to understand that
climate change is an issue that they
have to deal with
all right so this whole project actually
we had a really good
advisory uh group of external
stakeholders regional planners municipal
planners nonprofit organizations and
about halfway through the project we
were very enamored with the flood
analysis we were doing and they said uh
cam
are towns even going to be able to use
this information
and uh i said why wouldn't they be able
to use this information well there's a
whole bunch of legal ramifications that
municipalities might be faced that they
wouldn't be able to use something that's
a scientific product but that hasn't
been sort of doesn't have the stamp of
approval of fema and so we said that's a
really good question we went out and got
some money from the noaa sea grant law
center and engaged in vermont law school
in a whole series of questions about
would municipalities be able to use this
scientific information so you ask
questions about is a municipality liable
for acting or not acting does it have
the authority to act
what happens if the maps are challenged
can a municipal municipality be sued if
they decide to take land based on what's
shown in the maps and what options do
communities have to protect the health
and property within their flood plains a
significant set
of questions and actually john
echeverria and his students worked on
this for two years and have developed
this this tremendous 150 page report
which i don't completely understand
because i'm not a lawyer i'm not about
to give you legal advice but i'll i'll
share with you the highlights but it's
if you're interested it's online at our
our
web page there 100 year floods the
bottom line is essentially as long as
you follow a transparent process
you're clear about what it is you're
trying to protect and you clearly cite
the information that you're using
municipalities in new hampshire have
considerable leverage to to make
decisions based on the information they
have sought so the bottom line is even
though the maps that we produced aren't
legal documents they can actually be
used for a town to change its zoning or
to or to change its riparian rights or
to ask people to build buffers or to ask
people to build further back from areas
and protection of the floodplains so
this is what it turns out this is what
the municipalities are way more
interested in than the new floodplain
maps can we actually use that
information and the analysis of new
hampshire law indicates that once again
as long as it's a very transparent
process and you're clear about what
you're trying to do you can use it
this is another piece of sort of small
victories come from strange places
a lot of our results we shared them with
a lot of different audiences across
across new hampshire several people who
work for the department of environmental
services and i had talked to the
commissioner of des and says look can we
change
the permitting process so that uh
instead of engineers using this tp40
manual they actually at least reflect
current conditions of 8.5 inches and he
said cam it's a really long process i
don't know what it takes but we probably
have to go to the general court and they
actually without ever talking to me
again they had actually talked about it
amongst themselves and decided that they
didn't have to to tell anybody they
could it was their permit process so
they could change it if they wanted to
so this anytime you move a lot of dirt
in new hampshire you have to fill out
this alteration of terrain permit
application an engineer does it and it's
several pages long and so embedded on
sort of the bottom of page six
is a
standard of practice right drainage
analysis and they now say that as you do
your your hydrological analysis your
rainfall amount has changed from the
northeast regional climate center where
it used to say tp40 so i could probably
do research for another 20 years and
would not have i don't i hope i will but
could not have an impact that i think
will be as big as this is now this might
be challenged in court because for an
engineering firm this is a big deal to
go from 6.3 to 8.5 inches in their
analysis even if they don't build to it
it's a big change for them
but i think people at des understand
that it's going to be good if we start
adapting today so small victory that may
have a big impact in the future
we've also we have a little piece of
coast we're not nearly as vulnerable as
connecticut is
we've got 17 miles of coast and people
are beginning to get concerned about sea
level rise although it's interesting
different communities are are
being concerned to different
uh different levels
clearly the big challenge here and this
is a relatively old vermeer and ram
store of projections out in the future
they're a little bit lower for the
latest ipcc but sort of uh about you
know
one to two feet by the middle of the
century two to six feet by the end of
the century and the big uncertainty here
comes from the fact that we really don't
know what's going to happen with
antarctica and greenland
the amount of ice that those ice sheets
are dumping in
to the ocean is increasing
probably in a large part because of ice
shelf dynamics and the way warmer sea
surface temperatures are changing those
ice shelf dynamics
eliminating the ice shelves and allowing
sort of that taking the cork out of the
bottle and allowing that ice to flow
down more rapidly to the ocean but you
can see that the rate so this is a
recently uh science paper by shepard so
the rate of the amount of sea level
that's being contributed by antarctica
and greenland is increasing
right so it's they're probably not going
to disappear overnight but we don't
actually completely understand the
internal dynamics of the site sheet so
there's lots of uncertainty and how is
it that you go about talking about this
uncertainty with instead of external
stakeholders
we'd argue and what i tell people is
start preparing for a foot by the middle
of the century a couple feet by the end
of the century and science will almost
certainly improve these estimates over
time we don't it's not going to happen
tomorrow although you know we dodged a
bullet you guys sort of did with sandy
we certainly
did
but the impact of a storm like that is
just going to be worse in the future so
at the very least prepare for something
as bad as that and i show this little
cartoon because people say oh we have an
11 foot tidal range you know what's a
couple of feet a sea level rise going to
be well the problem is not
uh at low tide the problems that a storm
that comes in at high tide and our big
storms are usually nor'easter's that
last two or three days
uh so we we always have something to
deal with at high tide which is where
the damage from sandy came from and then
if you look at our storm surge on the
coast of new hampshire it's about a a
nine foot storm surge from a from a
hundred year storm then you add a couple
feet of sea level rise or you add six
feet by the end of the century and if
worse comes to worse you actually have
that you're really unlucky and you have
it in your astronomically highest mean
high high water which is a couple
additional feed in new hampshire this is
actually to scale you start having water
coming in this
still water coming in the second floor
of your building down at rye beach
so we actually use this to estimate sort
of how high uh the this hundred year
flood would be uh in new hampshire in
the future and if you look at
so here's the 11.2 feet
current storm surge we might get under
higher sea level if it happens at king
tide sort of uh
19.7 feet and that's above this vertical
datum navd 88. if you put that above
mean high high water uh right we're
looking at about 7.2 to 15 feet above
mean high high water so we went out and
drew a series of maps that said let's
take sort of sort of a middle of the
road we had a flood that was 12 feet
above mean high high water what would
that look like for coastal new hampshire
and we drew this set of uh pretty uh
maps that were done by chris watson
watson from umass boston
and they've in many ways they've changed
the nature of the discussion uh in
coastal new hampshire let me show you
what we're showing here uh this isn't uh
sort of water depth in the ocean it's
this is this represents water depth over
the land so the yellow is zero to three
feet over the land right the red is
three to six feet the orange is six to
nine feet and the blue is greater than
nine feet of water
so i'm showing you a particular piece of
of the southern new hampshire coast so
massachusetts starts right here
this is seabrook nuclear power plant
right here you'll be happy to see right
we were very happy to see they actually
built it high enough
maybe
at least for this analysis we could have
a bigger storm uh than this but you'll
see
all this this is all beach this is all
really valuable real estate this is all
houses in here so this is these are the
sand dunes this is the big bowl behind
the sand dune and this is route one you
can see we're looking at six to nine the
greater than nine feet of water in these
communities right this is where almost
all of the value in seabrook resides and
i don't know how this town exists after
one of these floods
right and this is these are still water
elevations so we're not capturing the
dynamic aspect of the ocean the same is
true for hampton
you can see all this area behind the
beach right under more
than nine feet of water hampton just
built a four million dollar half shell
right here for its summer concert series
that i can't imagine is going to
last a decade or two uh paid for by new
hampshire taxpayers so uh we we've sort
of showed this set of maps to lots of
people and they're able to say well
we're vulnerable where are we vulnerable
and how do we begin to protect ourselves
so we've been involved in a couple of
different projects to actually go in and
talk to community members about what
they can start doing to protect areas
that are really significant to them such
as their wastewater treatment plants and
their schools and their police stations
and do the economic analysis on how much
money they might save if they go about
actually spending the money to protect
those
all right so getting close to the end
here
one of the ways that we've been taking
that message out is by
one of the projects that i'm really have
been
most enamored with that i've been
involved in it's called the new
hampshire
coastal adaptation work group so it was
really an ad hoc group of people that
got together from all of these different
organizations and we
decided that we just want to focus on
how it is that we raise i mean the
resilience of municipalities in coastal
new hampshire to future flooding both
fresh water and salt water and so we've
worked with a whole bunch of them but
it's the group that has come together
that has really begun to make a
difference because we've identified
vulnerabilities and then we've used that
to go out and actually get money to do
additional research to answer questions
that the community has raised as opposed
to what scientists have raised so we're
beginning to
really have significant discussions
about what communities can do and we're
getting a a wide range of
planners and emergency managers
interested in this topic without shoving
the issue of climate change down their
throat so i never lead in any of these i
sort of sit in the background and they
don't even say there's a climate
scientist in the room we just talk about
how has your community flooded and how
can we help you make it more resilient
in the future and we're making uh real
progress on that front
one of the outcomes is that durham is
now re rewriting their master plan and
they now have a climate adaptation
chapter that they've included into their
master plan and i went up to durham
that's right it's the university town
and actually did a presentation on
climate change you can even see they
used our maps on the cover of their
report
so this is the kind of progress that we
hope to make across the entire region
i was going to give you a couple of
other examples of work we've been doing
we've developed the climate action plan
as every new england state has i wanted
to actually just show you sort of one of
the challenging aspects of our climate
action plan we recommended 67 different
recommendations for reducing greenhouse
gas emissions
and one of them was that we want to
renovate every house in new hampshire so
that it uses 60 less energy
and so this is this is turning out to be
a vexing problem for me and the problem
that i actually want to solve
before i
move on to something else
so there's about half a million homes in
new hampshire so you can see we ramped
up the renovations but on the order
we're doing when we get up here we're
doing 15 000 renovations of new
hampshire homes per year right now we're
building a few hundred homes in new
hampshire and we're renovating a few
thousand so it's a it's a remarkable
change
and then we ramp up right so we get all
the renovations done by 2025. here's the
cost of the renovations here
and then here's the avoided energy costs
using very
conservative estimates of what energy is
going to cost in the future but the real
challenge here is that how do we go
about raising these billions of dollars
to renovate these homes when the
marketplace does not value energy
efficiency right the marketplace values
granite countertops extra bedrooms and
extra bathrooms
so there's a huge challenge in how we
finance this and i'm now talking to a
whole set of
community loan funds and people who pool
private investments to see what
instruments we can't use to actually get
private money to help renovate those
homes and essentially to develop
power purchase agreements with
individual homeowners so they agree to
pay a set price for energy for 10 years
entities come in renovate the home they
don't use any predetermined technology
they just figure out the best way to
save energy for that home and at the end
of 10 or 15 years the homeowner ends up
owning whatever the equipment is so how
we finance this stuff is beginning to uh
to be a significant question for me
a couple more slides
we've also recently been funded by the
national science foundation for a
research coordination network to
actually engage climate scientists and
engineers
uh it turns out that this has been a
much bigger challenge and the engineers
of the climate scientists thought uh one
thing uh one one aspect of this came out
really early in our uh
our conversations is we were talking
about sort of conservative estimates and
when you talk to a climate scientist a
conservative estimate is something he
estimates that will almost certainly
come true right so a conservative
estimate for sea level rise is on the
lower end a conservative estimate for an
engineer is mean they build the hell out
of something so it will withstand
anything so it has completely different
meanings to two different groups of
people and it wasn't until our second or
third meeting that we started to
understand that we were actually using
the same word to mean something
completely different but we're really
trying to engage a broad group we're
trying to disseminate information
developing a web-based knowledge page
comments specifically about climate
scientists for engineers collaborate
we're trying to build a network and
we're really doing this exploration to
see if we can't get engineers to really
think about designing in a world where
climate is not stationary that's our big
challenge
so my last slide what path will we take
to the future
all being all good new englanders here
we all know robert frost's poem about a
path diverging in the woods you guys
aren't all new englanders but if you're
here you should certainly at least read
this poem right
um and so i would argue that we're at
this fork in in the road in the woods uh
and we've been here for 10 years and
we're sort of going down the pathway of
uh using more fossil fuel energy and not
really addressing this problem and i
would argue we have to be on the other
path not only does society have to
change i think the road less traveled
for academics is to get more and more
engaged in trying to solve societal
problems
so i'll stop there and answer your
questions